not so long ago
V Becca Morrissey and Ken Olson thought
that one day they would go for walks
here with their child but almost since
birth their daughter has been a ward of
the Norwegian child welfare agency I
feel they take all that I've been
created for away from me I was created
to be a father a protector of my family
and they take the possibility away and
we got some things here this is our just
band and this is all her things this is
her bathtub and this is all her playing
things and baby Jim but we are never
used it before because she she has never
been been home Ken Olson makes no secret
of his past involving drugs violence and
prison terms he himself grew up in state
homes their daughter was to be a living
symbol of the parents new beginning so
well that Ken was the two dangers for me
and Aria so they took me another from
the hospital but after one week they
decided that no I'm not a good enough
mother either so they took Aria now the
baby lives with her foster family her
parents are allowed only occasional
visits but why before re was born
neighbors had called the police on the
parents because of a domestic
disturbance and Ken had a record in
Norway that's grounds enough to call in
the youth welfare office doesn't grip it
in although in cases where the youth
welfare office has intervened it's been
because of a report and information from
doctors or other authorities about it
and then we intervene only to prevent
the child's health or welfare from being
harmed these father's it's me also put
him on my bond right Norman the offices
hardline methods have made headlines
dozens of cases have been denounced in
internet forums many of the parents who
public with their experiences are
foreigners whose children have been
taken away by the authorities there have
been demonstrations around the world
against Norway's rigid child welfare
policies Anika cleaner Ekpo Funan says
the youth welfare office removes
children from the home as a first resort
not as the last she used to work for the
office but quit because she could no
longer condone its practices the child
welfare office is only concerned with
removing the children from the families
as quickly as possible and not helping
to bring them back again quickly they
stay with foster families until they're
18 no discussion as a social worker for
the child welfare office she was under
constant pressure rather than support
the parents long term she had to wrap up
one case and move on to the next we had
lists of mothers we specifically
targeted single mothers are ones with
kids from several fathers poor sick
unemployed parents or families without
relatives that is uncles aunts or
grandparents in Norway twice as many
children are placed in homes and foster
families per capita as in Germany for
example the strict child protection
rules call for parents who are beyond
reproach
in most Canton avian countries spanking
is taboo this is often where immigrant
parents run afoul of local authorities
this is not scientific it's a cultural
thing that you that we believe that you
should not hit the children in order to
learn while they come from a culture who
believes is different and and it's
interesting to see on a longitudinal
study if there are differences when they
grew up
but we can't say that 15 year-old girl
was immobilized by police just because
she wanted to stay with her parents such
methods in the name of child welfare
been condemned by Norwegian courts but
even so when foreigners get caught up in
the Norwegian system cultures can and do
clash that's obvious
we have our own definition of what's
best for the child and it's clear and
easy to understand for everyone who
lives here for so long no but it's a
challenge to put it across and you have
to expect cultural conflicts till folks
a little on that but it's not solely a
question of cultures the Norwegian child
protection policies are legally
questionable as well attorneys have
occasionally succeeded in returning
children to their parents in the
Norwegian authorities doing a lot of
things wrong because international law
says that they should not take the
children out of harm if not it's
necessary and I think a lot of cases it
not necessary the rigid child protection
laws once separated Ken Olsen from his
mother now he's determined to do
whatever it takes to get his own child
back he's never had the chance to be a
loving caring father